because i would argue that we're living
through the equivalent of another axial
age
we have no idea how to respond to the
world in which we live
because while we still have many of the
problems
that the philosophers of the actual age
were discussing
and presented to us we have a vast array
of new problems that have completely and
totally befuddled us
our religions our cultures our
constitutions our legal systems
our social norms our language basically
our philosophical systems
don't know how to address them
this is my central argument for next
year and so
yeah it's just that easy should be no
problem um
and uh and so how
we need to reshape our thinkings and our
minds and our actions
to do essentially what the philosophers
began doing 2
000 plus years ago
faced with all these new opportunities
faced with all these new problems faced
with these new systems and structures
and ways of thinking and technological
innovations
how do you respond when certain
things just don't work the same way
anymore and i'll just give you one
example
uh that that goes back to the axial age
when you start meeting foreign peoples
you have a couple of choices the first
choice usually is kill them
if you decide not to kill them then you
have to figure out how to live with them
so you can either exclude them
or you can start mixing with them and
when you start mixing with them well
then you come up with all these
crazy marriage laws marriage laws are
always fun
anthropologists love to look at all the
different rules we've come up with for
ways to marry
but in theory the marriage costumes that
we have have been inherited from
cultures that go back
way before the axial age
probably running to pre-agrarian ages
sometimes so we have customs that were
developed over ten thousand years ago
that still have this incredible
influence on a society 10 000 years
later
now if nothing fundamental has changed
in your society in the intervening 10
000 years your custom is probably just
fine it seems like things have changed
that's my theory uh and it means
not irrationally that institutions like
marriage
struggle and we have all these debates
now about marriage in all kinds of
different ways
and in fact we've changed our marriage
culture dramatically without saying that
we've changed it we keep saying we're
doing the same thing and we don't do the
same thing at all
which is a classic sign that you're your
your intellectual and cultural norms are
not keeping up with what's actually
going on
um and so that sort of ancient five ten
thousand year old custom
is having a rough time of it because the
world in which that custom was developed
is
long long long gone
and so trying to understand how
ancient institutions ancient ideas
translate into a new world with new
forces
new concepts new cultures it's
it's virtually hard it's really hard
basically it's virtually impossible in
fact it's a stupid idea for a lecture
series let's just say that
right up front let's just be let's just
be clear on that
and yeah i think it's worth a shot for
the same reason that the people were
giving it a shot a couple of thousand
years ago
we don't think of them as facing
technological innovation but they were
i mean when someone develops a new kind
of pot
those burns those beautiful urns that
they shipped everything in man i wish
amazon would ship things in grecian urns
wouldn't that be great
because then i would really like to get
stuff from amazon i would just throw out
what was ever inside and just keep those
beautiful urns right
no we get ugly boxes earns let's push
for earns
but that though that development of a
new urn
does a couple of things like people go
oh that's beautiful we want it
two it's very efficient at carrying this
so we need to copy that
and three it means that your potters
your people who make this they have to
change
and so what we call you know technology
advancing it was already happening
the second a ship lands with a superior
product
all of your crafts people and your
traders go
problem gotta solve that
because it's going to bankrupt us if we
just keep buying all that stuff
the classic example here is the opium
wars if even people know the opium war
history is
england had nothing that china wanted
and china had everything that england
wanted
so england was sending basically all of
its gold and silver
to china and so england was like we
gotta find something to sell the chinese
and they came up with
opium which was a very friendly solution
if we can get a lot of chinese people
addicted to opium that would be great
because we run india so that's cool
um and then the chinese were like no we
don't think you should be allowed to
sell your drugs in our country so that a
war
and the end of the war was whoa no it'd
be lovely if you sold us through drugs
um
and then england got their gold back
right so there was act
that i mean this and that's not two
thousand years ago that's his recent
history
that the fact that england couldn't come
up with something to
compete with the goods from china forced
them to go to war with china
and this was this was happening in the
ancient world just over and over again
where somebody developed something
that's better knew you either outlawed
that was always
popular oh no nobody can buy that but
then that tended not to work smuggling
has been popular for a long long time
and so then you go we have to do
something to compete we either have to
conquer those people
we have to force them to integrate with
our society or we need to just copy it
make something like it that people here
will consume and this will balance
things out again
so we think of our time we are living in
a time of unprecedented technological
development
but the response started
2 400 years ago the necessity
of reshaping your thinking to continuous
pressure from outside technologies
outside markets outside
people's outside ideas
that's what's new about the axial age
before then you could live moderately
isolated
you could have a small controlled space
or even a large controlled space
where very few people had access to any
resources and so they just told
everybody else what to do
99 slaves one percent ruling you know
five percent ruling
but i don't know exactly what the
percentage reaches but at some point
when seven or eight or nine percent of
your population
is not working in the fields and is
literate
and skilled and has some capacity and
some free time
you get problems
and history is perfectly clear if you
try to control those problems by
isolating your country you fail
you either fail today or you fail
tomorrow or you fail in 75 years
but basically eventually someone is
going to have worked out something
that destroys your way of life
and so this process that feels so
inevitable
still so modern feel this constant
pressure of new ideas new concepts new
goods
new technologies started there
or